Marcelle Julien alors vous euh vous avez
été donc Dégé de de cette maison là et
aussi question comment se fait-il que
vous y accepter alors que vous étiez un
éditeur prospère et heureux de vous
mettre dans ces d'attirer à vous ces
orages non désirés comme vous dites dans
votre livre il a pas perdu sa prospérité
non non mais que non ce que je voudrais
répondre de la même façon que Jean parce
que c'est vrai que on on a envie de
changer toujours la vie ou de la voir
venir euh puisqu'on vous propose quelque
chose je dis pas qu'il faut le prendre à
moins que ce soit une chose qui vous
déplaise fondamentalement et dans
l'ensemble passer un certain temps qui
est sueli de l'adolescence on nous
propose plus que des choses qui nous
plaisent à peu près qui aurait tendance
à nous plaire et puis il y avait une si
vous voulez je dans le sur le plan de
l'édition où je me trouvais il y avait
des hypothèques et des hypothèse
concernant la un empire auquel je
j'appartenais et donc je savais que il
allait avoir par par le départ de son
chef qui était Swan nsen président des
pr la cité des problèmes de d'apparente
succession auquel je ne voulais pas me
trouver mêlé donc quand on m'a donné la
porte de sortie très inattendue vers la
télévision et parce que la télévision me
fascinait puis l'idée de changer me
fascinit je n'ai pas hésité pu cétait un
risque oui c'est un risque qui est
partout même là où on reste alors
maintenant vous êes êtes vous avez passé
3 ans dans cette maison
rétrospectivement qu'est-ce que de quoi
êtes-vous fier le plus fier fier al je
voudrais je voudrais être clair à peu
près à peu près de de rien fier content
cont oui content d'un certain nombre de
choses qui sont état d'esprit qui semble
apparaître maintenant que l'on que l'on
ne ressentait pas ou l'on ressentait mal
lorsque j'étais là c'est-à-dire que j'ai
essayais de donner la liberté les
libertés d'expression les libertés
d'esprit au plus grand nombre de gens et
à peu près à tous ce qui passe toujours
pour ceux qui ne sont pas de cette
opinion pour une position politique pour
une impertinence ou pour une provocation
je crois que quel que soit le moment des
responsabilités que l'on nous confie
d'abord je voudrais faire une énorme
différence entre responsabilité et
pouvoir je crois c que j'ai écouté tout
à l'heure gens parler de de son peu
d'agrément à recevoir des ordres et donc
de son peu d'agrément en donner je crois
que le goût du pouvoir appartient à
certaines personnes je ne pense pas que
ça soit son cas ni le mien le sens des
responsabilités c'est autre chose alors
nous devions bien nous douter et si nous
disions aujourd'hui qu'on ne s'en
doutait pas un peu nous serions problème
probablement plus des romanciers comme
je viens de les définir que des que des
historiens je pense que nous on se
doutait bien qu'il y aurait ses ces
poids sur les choses mais qu'on pensait
qu'on avait peut-être petite mission
d'essayer de les alléger alors on y est
allé et rétrospectivement qu'est-ce qui
vous chagrine le plus mais ce qui me
chagrine c'est tout ce que j'ai pas
réussi c'est beaucoup c'està-dire
j'aurais préféré scandaliser moins et
déranger plus et déplacer davantage
alors c'est plutôt c'est dans la trace
non pas de mon action mais la trace des
idées concernant les libertés que
j'attends de savoir si j'ai fait quelque
chose de bien ou de mal c'est donc
plutôt à vous Bernard qui là et à
d'autres que de répondre qu'à moi vous
regrettez vous regrettez pas de ne plus
être non je crois que l'idée de de
regret est une idée alors quand on
change non pas souvent puisqueaprès tout
je suis resté 16 ou 17 ans dans
l'édition et dans la même travée
d'édition je crois que quand on quitte
une chose c'est que il fallait partir et
que il faut s'occuper de ce qui est
devant soi et de la tâche devant
l'établi et que on n pas de regard en
arrière non pas parce qu'on méprise non
pas parce qu'on napprécie pas et parce
que il faut toujours avoir tant de pain
sur la planche que on ne regrette pas
les les mis ou les croûes de Al vous
regrettez d'autant moins d'ailleurs que
ça vous a permis d'écrire cet ouvrage
pour lequel vous avez une presse très
très chaleureuse et c'est la première
fois depuis longtemps que j'ai une
presse oui c'est vrai oui ça vous a fait
plaisir justement oui non non ça
incontestment ça fait plaisir on serait
s de dire le contraire non mais il y a
quelque chose de plus important que
faire plaisir c'est que c'est que je
voudrais qu' en tout petit je me dis
donc que l'on peut comprendre que qu'il
existe sur le plan de des in attention
des gens qui essayent de se conduire
correctement alors que quand on est
placé dans sur la place publique
derrière une vitrine comme des
demoiselles de Hambourg on a tendance à
vous considérer comme pass réconenable
ou c'est normal êtes-vous sûr de
toujours dire la vérité dans ce que vous
rapportez je reprends totalement les les
les phrases de Jean dormeon si vous
voulez je m'étais beaucoup posé le
problème par la même tentation qui fait
éc à la barbe blanche je m'étais demandé
s'il fallait pas faire un jour et je
crois que ce serait une bonne formule un
libre où il y aurait î et jeu
c'està-dire que tout ce qu'on aurait
voulu vivre tout ce qu'on nous c'est pas
dire parce que ça implique quelqu'un ou
tout ce qui est la la la l'imergé de
notre de notre existence rêver on le met
à î et on dis à je mais quand je dis je
je suis né tel jour du moins pour autant
que je le sache je dis une chose que je
crois vrai bon vous êtes d'ailleurs deux
vagabonds parce que il y a le vagabond
Sal et puis vous deslit vagabond vous
êtes de deux vagabonds et nous sommes
deux messieurs ex aussi de et deux ex et
vous avez été tous les deux mes patrons
d'ailleurs c'est vraiment lequel
préférez-vous Bern le seul survivant
c'est Bernard c'est moi je suis pas un
vagabond moi je je suis stable comz
alors le oui je faire remarquer alors ce
vous vagabondez effectivement vagabondez
dans vos souvenirs votre genunèse quand
vous avez été prisonniers des Allemands
quand vous avez été l'éditeur du général
de Gaulle où on va avec vous et Colom
les deux églises et puis finidemment
vous vous racontez pas mal de choses sur
ce qui s'est passé dans cette maison
durant 3 ans euh mais finalement quand
on vous lit on se dit que vous aviez une
vocation c'était la vocation d'écrivain
tout jeune vous vouliz être écrivain
c'est plutôt gentil ce que vous dites
mais mais je veux dire moi je l'avais
seulement je je alors je parle
sérieusement quand on a été éditeur et
que le hasard et la joie d'être éditeur
sont profondes il y a un problème très
grave j'ai été frappé par une phrase
très malencontreuse qu'un de mes
successeurs à la PR de mes précesseurs à
la présidence d'une de C sociétés de
d'édition MADIT un jour il m'a dit en me
recevant parce que il s'agissait de la
correspondance de Bernanos et que dans
la correspondance de Bernanos il y avait
des phrases un peu sévères pour lui il
m'a dit quand je pense que bernano je
l'ai fait et ça m'a glacé pour
l'éternité qu'on puisse dire qu'on a
fait un écrivain donc je me suis senti
pendant que j'étais
éditeur une envie folle d'écrire la
nécessité de le faire pour être honnête
envers les pulsions de jalousie
éventuelle que l'on a envers des autant
de talents que l'on fréquente et j'ai eu
aussi l'hygiène et la terreur
probablement de le faire donc quand j'ai
quitté la télévision et que j'ai vu que
j'allais replonger dans l'édition je me
suis dit tu as un moment de noyade si tu
louves celui-là tu le feras jamais plus
alors j'ai fait très vite ce livre non
mais vous racontez dans votre livre que
vous avez écrit je ne sais à quel âge
avec votre professur de français une
pièce de théâtre oui oui ça c'est
heureusement on a de la chance le pire
n'est jamais assuré parce que il a
vraiment cru qu'on allait la monter je
crois que ça failli se faire il
connaissait très bien Madame Paul rô qui
était directrice de l'œuvre on avait
écrit un petit cheédœvre ça Remel âge
j'avais 15 ans et demi 16 ans et avec
votre professeur de français av écritou
on avait écrit une pièce qui s'appelait
vivre c'était très simple on était des
gens très très simple et puis et je
devais lui apporter cette espèce de
fraîcheur de jeunesse cette espèce
d'impertinence et la dame jusqu'au
dernier moment lui a fait croire ou a
cru qu'elle le montait et si vous voulez
pour que ma mon arbre généalogique ne
soit pas très pourri au départ on peut
dire que Madame Paul rô je peux lui
mettre de des fleurs à chacun de ses
anniversaires elle l'a pas pris ouis
elle l'a pas pris mais vous à la fin
vous racontez que ce même professeur de
français vous a présenté un manuscrit
vous étiez directeur de plomb et vous le
lui avez refusé oui il traverse un peu
mon livre ce ce professeur de français à
diverses reprises parce que ça s'est
comme passé comme ça dans ma vie et là
j'ai vraiment ce ce regret parce que
c'est un peu saut il estit venu au tout
dernier moment il me disaittu à l'époque
et je lui disais vous j'étais très
impressionné on avait signé un contrat
où on avait mis tous les deux entre
monsieur J'ai et Marcel julon homme de
lettres au pluriel j'avais 15 ans et
demi c'était c'était fantastique et je
revois ce monsieur qui pour moi restait
un personnage presque mythique pour
lequel j'avais une admiration
nécessaire il vient il m'apporte un
manuscrit il m'appelle Monsieur le
Directeur il me dit vous et brusquement
toute la jeunesse est cassée j'espère
que tu l'as pas tutoyer non j'aurais dû
pour essayer de sauver nos rapports et
puis j'ai j'osais pas lire ce livre je
craignais ce que je craignais est arrivé
c'est qu'il était vraiment un un livre
très très attentif très précautionneux
et plein de tellement de belles phrases
que çaen était décourageant alors je
l'ai fait lire puis fait relire et puis
j'ai évité de répondre parce que je
pensais que le pire était de répondre et
puis à un moment donné un deuxième
remord est venu de dire je lui manque de
respect alors je lui ai écrit que
c'était très très bon mais j'ai comme on
fait toujours mais que c'était une
maison d'édition qui ne méritait
peut-être presque pas ce livre là oh les
hypocrite et et et il est mort de jours
après pas de ça mais je regretterai
toute ma vie d'avoir pas avoir attendu 3
jours de plus Michel